we've used the term stochastic terrorism
before on the show stochastic terrorism
is sort of the idea that while not being
a physical in-person terrorist yourself
if you have a big enough audience and
you float an idea to them of doing
something with a big enough audience it
becomes statistically more and more
likely that someone in the audience is
going to listen to what you're saying
and they're going to go out there and
they're going to commit an act of terror
we've looked at a number of these
examples in the past one is a guy
who used to listen to glenn beck rant
and rave about an organization called
the tides foundation and was actually
intercepted by california highway patrol
armed and heading to do something at the
tides foundation comet ping pong is
another example when republicans were
going crazy about the pizzagate
conspiracy theory and this pizza shop in
washington dc and saying they're
harboring pedophiles they're helping
pedo you know whatever it was they were
saying
pedophiles are meeting here and
trafficking young kids or whatever a guy
actually went and shot up comet ping
pong so there's a real effect here
republicans
a republican audience listening to
the chairman of the oklahoma republican
party john bennett who's also running
for house of representatives they
cheered when john bennett said
we should kill fauci we should put fauci
in front of a firing squad now i'm
certain that john bennett is a pro-life
and i'm certain that john bennett uh is
a christian
because there's uh a jersey up on the
screen behind him that says
aphasians ephesians i don't even know
how to pronounce it and there's a cross
and so this is a pro-life christian guy
in case you weren't sure and here he is
saying well we should put fouchy in
front of a firing squad we're fighting
communist democrats no you're not
there's no communists in the house and
senate establishment rhinos we're
fighting against a system that stole the
election in 2020 and nobody's been held
accountable
[Applause]
we're in a war with bureaucrats that
have forced vaccine mandates on us
masked mandates on us and you know what
they're pushing this wokeness confusion
down our throats now and by the way we
should try anthony fauci and put him in
front of a firing squad a firing squad
whoa
[Applause]
and the crowd loves it they love it
and for the secret service that they're
listening
i'm not advocating we kill anthony fauci
until he's convicted of his crimes
through a court right a nice little
clarification there now of course this
this guy is very pro-life and he
respects life and he's christian and all
these different things now threatening
government officials in the united
states
is illegal under federal law my guess is
the law doesn't apply to john bennett
right that that wouldn't really make any
sense
so kill anthony fauci put him in front
of a firing squad um
this is unfortunately not something we
can just laugh off and write off
there are really truly dangerous people
who want to see fouchy dead you know how
we know it isn't a joke
fauci has full-time armed security
he did anyway for the years during the
heart of the pandemic i don't know if
they've been able to ease up on it now
or not my guess is if stuff like this is
going on he probably still needs the
full-time armed security now lots of
people would say something like this
about a public figure
in a social media status update and you
would get a visit from law enforcement
if you said it about the president or
vice president or maybe even the speaker
of the house or a prominent senator you
might even get a visit from secret
service and yet here it's become normal
to call for executions in public forums
and then you say to secret service i'm
not really there you know we'll kill
them after we try them or whatever even
if like what are you the debt why would
they even get the death penalty for
whatever you think they did which they
didn't
this is proof
that you have this critical mass
of lack of intelligence
glorified by a base of people who are
extraordinarily radical and the
fear-mongering that's used against them
remember this is the reactionary toolbox
can be used to actually trigger them to
go out and take real world actions and
remember that uh you know we we were
told time and time again
that this movement that is being built
the maga movement and so on and so forth
this is a special movement this is a a
unique movement it was unique in that
these were a lot of people
who because they had never followed or
been involved in politics before
they had no idea of what was over the
line when it came to political discourse
and as a result
trump combined with these folks who had
i don't know they just like i guess
trump's the guy i never really paid
attention to politics what trump does
must be normal
it immediately
normalized for lack of a better term
um this type of political discourse
locking up people that haven't even been
in charge with a crime
uh talking about eliminating people
firing squads etc now how many of them
are actually willing to do violence i
don't think it's that many but the thing
is
think through some numbers
73 74 million people voted for donald
trump
if it's only two percent of those voters
that are willing to do violence right
that's still a million and a half people
that's that's a lot of people who are
potentially willing to do violence a lot
of the people willing to do violence
also don't vote at all so it's probably
actually an even higher number
unfortunately when you look at numbers
like one in four republican voters
believe some aspect of q anon
it's probably more than two percent of
those republican voters that are
theoretically willing to use violence
and you know what we know it's more how
do we know a recent poll found that
about 30 percent of republicans believed
it would be acceptable to use violence
now that doesn't mean they'd be the ones
doing it but if 30 of republicans say
violence would be acceptable
at least a portion of them would be
willing to go out and do it so
unfortunately the numbers aren't good
and we're gonna go on now to something
else where it's really not looking good